[Music]
now as John just reported Biden is
wheels up for his trip to Israel but as
he was on his way to Andrews his big
meeting in Jordan was
cancelled joining me now to discuss this
Florida Senator Marco Rubio senator the
president was already flying into a
difficult situation but given today's
events in Gaza the protests we're
hearing about at American embassies
Israeli embassies what are the stakes
here well first of all this is all part
of the Hamas Playbook and and Hezbollah
and Iran for that matter they don't just
want to go in and kill a bunch of
civilians slaughter babies terrible
Stories We keep hearing coming out then
they want to damage Israel around the
world and that and so that's that's why
they take advantage of this and they
know that there are all these willing
media Outlets not just Al jazer but the
initial reports from some American news
outlets was that Israel had struck a
hospital so they know how to play Israel
ever plan to strike a hospital it would
make no sense number one it would hurt
them correct it would hurt them and they
know that and the first the second is I
look at the end of the day if you ask me
to choose do I believe Israel or do I
believe the people that just slaughtered
a bunch of babies I believe Israel but
beyond that it makes all the sents in
the world I'm glad they're going to
release this footage there is side by
side with the actual kinetic battle that
you're seeing you have an informational
war going on and unfortunately it has
all these people that join it both on
the farle in American politics much of
the media around the world and and I
predict at some point you'll start to
see that seep into a lot of the coverage
here as well we're still talking about
the atrocities but the day is coming
when the whole Focus will be on how mean
Israel is because they are eradicating a
group that that poses an extraordinary
threat to their future and has already
Comm
incredible atrocities Senator Rubio
what's the strategy do you think of the
IDF they go into Gaza um we're going to
get into this a little later but the
word quagmire mired in Conflict how do
you get out you get in and how do you
get out you know take out Hamas we
understand that I I think part of it is
is still developing honestly and part of
it I think I would leave the military
tacticians to talk exactly about what to
do I think the goal though is to make
sure that Hamas is never in a position
to Once to do in the future what they
did at this moment and beyond that I
think it's important for Israel's
enemies to understand what happens when
you do these kinds of things to Israel
Israel doesn't just respond with 10
rockets and a condemnation and writing
you pay a tremendous price this is a
part of the world where the only
language that's understood is the
language of strength Israel didn't start
this war they didn't want this war this
war was foed upon them and now they have
to do what needs to be done is a nation
that is literally fighting for its
survival as it is surrounded by enemies
that seek their destruction now Biden is
already asking Congress for another
hundred billion doll it looks like cross
this afternoon on Bloomberg and
elsewhere 100 billion for Ukraine and
Israel and a border kind of pittance to
the Border here at home thoughts on that
well first of all they shouldn't be
linked okay um I think that there is
support for Ukraine funding and I think
there is almost near unanimous with the
exception of some people that we know
who they are for supporting Israel I
don't think the two should be linked the
good news here is that a lot of the
defense agreements the US has with
Israel has been codified they already
have the Authority they have the
authority right now to pull forward
about $24 billion Congress has already
passed that and Israel frankly what
they're asking for is that we sell them
resupply if they start running low
ammunitions so I'm not against that I
think Israel will need we will need to
do something but I think we need to see
how this develops until we know
specifically what Israel is going to
need because it's very what they're
going to need for a fight in Gaza is
very different from what they're going
to need if it's a fight in Gaza and
against Hezbollah coming out of Lebanon
uh you have expressed serious concerns
about Visa holders in the United States
uh who are of an islamist bent who
support islamism political Islam now we
believe in the first amend we're going
to get into some of this later on as
well but what about that and the people
were allowing into this country isn't it
time to take the law it's the law the
law says if you are a supporter of a
terrorist organization you shouldn't
even have a Visa so now once you get
that Visa if you identify yourself as a
as as a himas supporter then you should
have your Visa canceled and you should
be removed from the country a lot of
people aren't going to identify but
that's basically well I think it's
pretty listen they they were able to go
and get all these people to take video
and find out who all the people were and
that went on January 6th to the capital
they spent a lot of resources
identifying those people I I think if
they wanted to they could go through the
roster of these organizations the people
that that signed those letters the
people that were out they protesting to
me it's very simple if you are in this
country on a student visa a professor to
teach uh journalist Visa you're a
visitor and then you come out and say I
support Hamas I support the slaughter of
babies you should be out of here and
your Visa should be yanked do you feel
confident that the 90,000 Afghans that
we allowed into the country after the
Afghan withdrawal that they're all you
know for the American way and they're
all going to be part of our well I think
that's a broader challenge that the
immigra the nature of immigration in
this country has changed it used to be
that people came to America because they
wanted to be Americans now you have
people that come to America but don't
necessarily rapidly assimilate for a lot
of different reasons you take 90,000
people from anywhere in the world and
you're going to have people that are
going to be you know a problem I I think
if you were an interpreter who risked
your life worked alongside f000 people
been pushing this Senator though they
they're like let him in Nikki Haley
until she was back people there are
people that Gaza people should be coming
in we've heard that well there are
people that certainly helped us in
Afghanistan risk their lives and we
should be grateful for that I don't
think the number as you said is 990,000
I I have real concerns about what that
is but I think the bigger problem we
have right now is is actually in many
cases and the First Amendment does apply
unfortunately in this regard are people
that were born in this country to see
signs that's how a sign last week that
said lgbtq for Hamas does anyone want to
break the news to these people about
what life is like in places that are
governed by people like that not just
for for gay and lesbian people but but
but for women what life is like for
these it is so ridiculous but we have a
higher education system that's combined
with a corporate media that has poisoned
the minds of an entire generation of
Americans unfortunately and and it's a
real problem for this country moving
forward Trump wanted five billion for
the wall we've given Ukraine $120
billion well let me tell you something
and I think that's another challenge we
have no country in the world Egypt is
not allowing a mass migration of
Palestinians into Egypt border is in
trouble well we're policing a lot of
other borders but the bigger problem in
the borders they're not enforcing the
law that these people turn themselves
over to border patrol and they do
nothing they let them right in yeah and
a special special interest um migr yeah
um great to see you Senator thanks so
much for coming in hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else